nature is lawful as far as we can tell
the universe and all that it is made of
changes from moment to moment according to fixed
unchangeable immutable patterns and those patterns
as it tested to by a couple hundred years of
observation and calculation can be expressed
in the language of mathematics indeed
it is this mathematics right here
that describes the fundamental equations of
the world within this mathematics we have a
description of einstein's general theory of
relativity the standard model of particle
physics equations that describe how the force of
gravity works how the electromagnetic force works
how the strong and weak nuclear forces
work and all the particles of matter
on which those forces act this takes us
tantalizingly close to the reductionist dream of a
theory of everything at least at the level of the
fundamental laws and the fundamental ingredients
now i can well imagine that if you're not familiar
with all of this you may still be wondering
what does that really mean i mean how do these
symbols describe these particles well the answer
is that we can use mathematics to delineate the
configuration of the particles we can use numbers
to describe where the particles are and how the
particles are moving or in the quantum mechanical
language the probabilities for those qualities and
we can use mathematics to describe the intrinsic
features of those particles right i mean
the the mass of a particle that's a number
the amount of electric charge that a particle has
that's a number the spin of a particle that is a
number two and here's the thing we can take all
of these numbers as input and use the mathematical
equations to produce as output another set
of numbers that delineates the configuration
and the properties of those particles at any
subsequent moment in time that is how mathematics
can encapsulate the patterns followed by all of
nature's ingredients the fundamental ingredients
of everything as they evolve from moment to moment
through time now this is a remarkable achievement
showing how mathematics can describe the universe
at a fundamental level but even long before these
modern developments mathematics had already
shown itself capable of giving deep insights
into the workings of the world i mean even even 20
centuries ago the greek mathematician eratosthenes
he was able to use mathematics to figure
out the size of the earth and the pattern
that eratosthenes used is a is a very simple one
he noted that the difference in the lengths of
shadows cast by two identical sticks at
a given separation from one another the
difference in the lengths of those shadows depends
sensitively on the size of the earth right i mean
earth gets bigger and bigger the less and less
the difference between those lengths become
and so by actually measuring the difference
in the lengths of the shadows cast by two
identical sticks actually calculating the angle
of those shadows but it's all the same in the end
eratosthenes was able to figure out the size of
planet earth that's a a remarkable demonstration
of the capacity of mathematics to reveal qualities
of the world that are seemingly beyond our ability
to measure now some centuries later isaac
newton took this idea of using math to describe
reality took it to an extraordinarily new level
through careful observation and thought about
how objects move newton was able to discern
patterns in the motion of those objects perhaps
most famously he found that if you if you push on
an object if you exert a force on it that object
it will speed up it will accelerate and that
acceleration is proportional to the force
and inversely proportional to the mass of the
object embodied in newton's famous second law
of motion now newton also found that if you
have two objects out there in space the pull
of one object on the other through gravity will
be proportional to the product of their masses
and inversely proportional to the square of their
separation that's newton's famous universal law
of gravity and these equations are central to
what came to be called classical physics and
what a what a stunning picture of the world
classical physics gives us if you provide me with
the positions and the velocities of all objects
all particles we can use the mathematics of
classical physics to predict the configuration the
motion and positions of those particles tomorrow
the next day the next year the next millennia
or a billion millennia into the future
newton kind of likened the universe to a grand
cosmic clockwork you you wind up the universe
and the mathematical laws then dictate how the
universe ticks forward in time whether it's a
turning cog or a spinning wheel or a tumbling
raindrop or a hurtling rock or the orbiting moon
newton's mathematics gave us an
astoundingly precise description of
the natural world and on occasion when newton's
mathematics seemed to be a little bit off
oftentimes it was actually just pointing toward
some hidden feature of reality back in the mid
19th century astronomers noticed that the orbit
of uranus had some irregularities that that could
not be accounted for using newton's universal
law of gravity but they also found that those
irregularities they had their own inner
pattern a pattern that could be explained
if one imagined that there was a hidden
hitherto unknown planet out there in space
whose gravity was tugging on the planet uranus
and indeed the astronomers were able to calculate
where that hidden planet should be and on a
september night 1846 when those astronomers
turned their telescopes to the predicted
position in the night sky they discovered
the planet neptune a remarkable example of
mathematics revealing qualities of the world but
even newton's ideas newton's mathematics
was heading toward its own reckoning
early years of the 20th century scientists begin
to examine with precision the microscopic realm
molecules atoms subatomic particles and in that
domain the newtonian ideas however successful
they had been in describing motion in the skies
and motion here on earth the newtonian ideas were
giving predictions that were completely at odds
with the data remarkably it just took a single
generation of scientists to overhaul newton's
classical ideas giving us the quantum mechanical
description of the world a description in which
the universe evolves according to a mathematically
precise game of chance with the mathematics
given by a new quantum equation schrodinger's
equation an equation that makes its own astounding
predictions about the micro world it tells us that
particles should be able to penetrate through
seemingly impermeable barriers it tells us that
two distant particles can somehow influence
each other instantaneously across any distance
the math even predicts the existence of
particles that had never been seen before
and all of those predictions have now been
borne out by a mountain of experimental data
the quantum mathematics is jaw-droppingly
precise we can even use it to describe certain
properties of particles such as the magnetic
properties of electrons and the mathematics makes
predictions to many decimal places and when we do
the experiment the measured values agree with the
theoretical prediction digit by digit by digit
by digit a clear demonstration of the power of
mathematics to describe reality even right here
right we can see the work of quantum mechanics
in the fact that in this domain right now
this is what this room actually looks like
but using the power of quantum mechanics which
has given rise to the powerful computational tools
of the digital revolution we can take
this room and make it look like this
now all these successes of the mathematical
description of the world raise a number of
difficult and thorny questions right
i mean is is mathematics invented
or is it discovered that is is is math a
product of the human imagination is matha
a language that we have developed over the
course of many centuries for the express
purpose of articulating the patterns
that we encounter in the natural world
in a sense then is our sense that the world
is mathematical nothing but the fact that
we have developed a particular tool a kind of
mathematical hammer that makes everything look
like a mathematical nail or to the contrary is
math discovered is math out there independent
of of our understanding independent of us is it
deeply woven into the very fibers of reality and
if that is the case is it still possible that
there's something beyond mathematics perhaps
there's something beyond math that can illuminate
the most ephemeral and precious qualities
of human experience like like consciousness
and the kinds of things that conscious beings
contemplate like value ethics morality purpose
and meaning these are the kinds of questions
that we're going to be talking about here today
they're difficult they're contentious there is no
consensus on the answers to these questions but
these questions will surely drive an energetic
vibrant conversation on the relationship between
mathematics and reality all right let's get to it
so with that let me now bring in david albert
is the frederick e woodbridge professor of
philosophy at columbia university and a physicist
who explores the foundations of quantum mechanics
world-renowned for his insights into philosophical
questions about the nature of space time and
other problems of modern physics welcome david
albert next is sheldon goldstein a professor
of mathematics and physics and philosophy at
rutgers university he studies the foundations of
quantum theory probability theory and statistical
mechanics the notion of increasing entropy and
the arrow of time welcome shelley next is sylvia
jonas who is a professor of philosophy at munich
center for mathematical philosophy with a phd
in philosophy from humboldt university in berlin
she studies epistemology the philosophy of
mathematics science metaphysics meta ethics
philosophy of religion and aesthetics welcome
sylvia finally last but absolutely not least
is max tegmark a physicist cosmologist and machine
learning researcher at the massachusetts institute
of technology and a co-founder of the future of
life institute welcome max so thanks to all of you
for joining us for this conversation
about these issues that really people have
thought about struggled with come to a whole wide
variety of perspectives on over the course of
of truly hundreds if not thousands of years in
one form or another and i thought i'd begin to
set the stage with giving some quotes from famous
accomplished renowned mathematicians in the past
who weighed in with their own views on some of the
questions we'll be talking about just to sort of
set a bit of a backdrop of how the field has
viewed these questions so let me start with
chronicler god made the integers all the rest
is the work of man famous mathematician g
h hardy i believe that mathematical reality
lies outside us that our function is to discover
or observe it andrew wiles more in our generation
to tell you the truth i don't think i know a
mathematician who doesn't think that math is
discovered and wouldn't be right to end this list
of quotes without bringing in albert einstein
himself who once said as far as the laws of
mathematics refer to reality they are not certain
and as far as they are certain they do not refer
to reality all right so those are a whole variety
of perspectives on the invention question the
discovery question whether it's out there whether
it is something mathematics emerges from the
machinations of the human mind but let's begin
at the beginning if you will by just having a
little bit of the history of mathematics i mean
oftentimes when we learn mathematics in the
classroom at least when i learned in the classroom
it was just presented as his body of knowledge
there is no sense that this knowledge even
emerged from the struggles of of humans thinking
about things but of course mathematics as we
understand it as we practice it as we use it is a
body of insight that emerged over a long course of
history so sylvia can you just give us a thumbnail
sketch of the history of mathematical development
sure yes there are four stages in the unfolding of
mathematical history the beginning was in ancient
mesopotamia and babylon a tool that was used for
example calculating lunar calendars or measuring
plots of lands in order to determine who owns what
in ancient greece mathematics became
something quite different the ancient greeks
associated the laws of mathematics with something
that they consider to be ultimate reality
plato for example thought that ultimate reality is
not physical reality which is what we think today
but a sort of heaven of eternal forms not only
mathematical entities but also things like
beauty justice truth all of these with capital
letters as it were there is this famous legend
that it said on top of his academy let no one
ignorant of geometry enter here he believed
that mathematical knowledge was the only kind of
perfect knowledge and in order to gain knowledge
about any other thing you would first have to
be proficient in mathematics so ultimate reality
was seen to be in this platonic heaven outside
and completely different from physical reality
jumping ahead centuries during the time of the
scientific revolution things were completely
different all of a sudden scientists started
to discover that our physical reality follows
mathematical laws and that we can actually
explain empirical phenomena using mathematical
laws so in that sense ultimate reality was now
identified with physical reality and mathematical
and physical reality became two sides of
the same coin they were seen as interwoven
that picture changed again in the 19th century
with the introduction of mathematical concepts
that didn't have very straightforward relevance
for our physical world anymore non-euclidean
geometries for example so all of a sudden
mathematicians started to feel free to explore
mathematical entities that had no connection
to the empirical world anymore and that caused
a complete shift in the way mathematics was seen
no longer essential part of our physical reality
but as a tool that scientists can use but they
can also discard it their pleasure today things
have yet again changed we're at a point where we
can see that mathematical reality and physical
reality intersect but there are two separate
realities existing independently of one another
great so thank you for that history shelley you
know in that in that history that sylvia just
recounted and of course in your own experience
as a philosopher a mathematician who focuses on
questions about the physical universe do you
do you see math as this tool for describing the
external reality or do you see math as something
bigger than that in the language that sylvia was
saying touching upon a reality that perhaps goes
beyond the physical reality or is parallel to the
physical reality somehow separate from the
reality that's made up of tables and chairs
yes i i mean i certainly see it as a tool but
certainly see it as something beyond the tool
i guess for me however hard it is for even
me to understand even though it's my view
i think that mathematical reality
is the reality we know best
the reality that we can be most confident
about even if we have the sense that we
don't know where it is or how we could know it
given how we interact and gain with things and
gain knowledge there's so many mysterious things
about mathematics but at the end of the day i
do think it's the thing we know best and
it's the reality which we can have the most
confidence in and and so mathematical reality
it exists in in in human heads for sure right
so when we think about the ideas of mathematics
it amounts to something inside of a human brain
firing one way or another thinking about a square
root thinking about a factorial thinking about the
number 17 or whatever so so david are we fooling
ourselves in in thinking that math is somehow
out there touching some deeper reality when
in essence it's really just something that is
invented and lives the only place we're
certain that it lives in the human mind
i'm not sure that i have anything particularly
deep to say about this um and i should say to the
audience david always begins every answer that
way and he always has something deep but anyway
i mean there's a famous 20th
century philosopher um named quine
one of the things he's famous for is a criterion
for what we should take to be real for what our
discourse commits us to thinking
actually exists basically the idea is
if there's something that we find we can't
do science without talking about as if it's
a real thing then we should count it as real and
otherwise we shouldn't quine famously thought that
that certain claims about numbers are the
kinds of things that you have to talk about
as if the numbers are real things other
people people who were very interested
in crime's criteria but thought he might have
made a misjudgment about this particular case
people famously like hartree field for example
have tried to show that there are ways of doing
science without acting as if numbers are
are real objects um out there in the world
i think it might be it might be useful to regard
this as a scientific question and you allow that
to guide your beliefs about what may exist and and
what may not exist and the guide is essentially
if you find that there's a certain kind of object
whose existence you need to commit yourself to
in order to get the scientific project done
then you ought to believe in that if not not
so so just every when you like are are
playing with the schrodinger equation from
quantum mechanics which is a subject that
you've spent a lot of time thinking about
uh if you're not thinking hard about the
question of invention versus discovery
do you have a sort of working methodology that's
in the back of your mind that views this as a mere
description of the world versus when you write
down schrodinger's equation you're like this is
the world there are lots of physicists who like
to say it's a great mystery this question of how
mathematics applies to the world why mathematics
applies to the world why we're so lucky
as for it to be the case that mathematics applies
to the world fraga famously says i don't see what
these people are talking about i can't imagine
a situation in which mathematics would fail
to apply to the world somebody says to me i
have two apples over here and i have another two
apples over here um isn't it a miracle that the
fact that mathematically abstractly two plus
two equals four applies to these apples i'm
tempted to turn the the question on its head
it's very difficult for me to imagine
what the world would have to be like
in order for that to fail to be the case so max
jumping off from that i know you have very strong
views on the reason why mathematics does work in
in the manner that we've been describing we're
going to come to that later on in the discussion
but just in a more cursory cursory way right now
math in your mind invented or discovered
discovered so it's out there yeah i think we
when people have these arguments is it invented or
discovered when people say it's invented i think
what they are often after is that the language
of mathematics is invented like we invent
the calligraphy by which we write the number five
because in china you can write it differently or
we invent the word for five you know
which in swedish is fem so obviously
that wasn't discovered we humans just kind
of made it up i think that's very analogous
to like if you look in the solar system and argue
about whether the whether the planet neptune was
invented or discovered obviously the name for
it was invented because in swedish we call it
neptunus there's a there's nothing fundamental
but the existence of neptune i would very strongly
argue is not something we made up it's just out
there and in exactly the same way when you go and
look for mathematical objects out there like plato
as as you mentioned brian was really interested in
these regular shapes called platonic solids and
he could invent the name dodecahedron for the
one that's made of 12 pentagons he could have
called it schmodecahedron instead if he wanted
but he couldn't invent the sixth one because
it doesn't exist just like you can't just
invent another planet in the solar system in that
sense i feel that these mathematical structures
really are discovered even though we invent the
language for talking about them well let me ask
the group do any of you allow for the possibility
that one day we're having a conversation with some
intelligent alien civilization and they ask
us okay what have you guys been doing to try
to figure out reality and we show them our
latest greatest mathematical description
of the world and they turn to us and they
kind of roll their eyes or they sort of
pat us on the head and say we understand that
direction mathematics we try that for a while
too but then we found that it was a dead end
and the real way for describing reality is this
and they give us some other description of the
world or or way of thinking about the world that's
not math it's not even disguised math it's just
something else do you allow that as a possibility
i certainly allow it as a possibility although i
wish i could imagine what that would be like but
probably it's important to distinguish between
whether or not our world has to be described
in mathematical terms that mathematics is the
language to express the nature of physical reality
and whether even if physical reality could
best be described in other terms there would
still be mathematical reality the validity of
mathematical reality wouldn't be diminished it
wouldn't be as you could be an imperialist about
mathematics and say mathematics is everything
you could be the opposite and say mathematics is
nothing i think the reasonable view is mathematics
is something but not everything but one of the
arguments that certainly has been put forward over
a long period of time for why math should be
viewed as really out there is in some sense
you know the the unreasonableness of mathematics
to quote a famous paper in describing how things
actually work in the world so just to be a con
give a concrete example when isaac newton was
writing down the universal law of gravity he
had access to certain observations certain
data to a certain degree of accuracy a certain
precision and you could imagine he wrote down
this formula that was able to describe the things
at that level of accuracy but then as the years
and decades go by our ability to measure the
world gets better and better and shockingly
newton's ideas continue to work and that leads a
sense of okay this is some deep actual truth of
the world not just some human description of the
world but then the counter-argument is at some
point the data becomes so precise that newton does
fail and of course we have to bring in einstein's
description of gravity a different equation
different mathematics so then it leads you to
believe well maybe newton's was just a provisional
description made up by a brilliant human mind
in the late 1600s and it was later replaced by
another description by another brilliant human
mind namely albert einstein and that seems to pull
us back to the idea of description as opposed to
the math being out there sylvia does either
of those ways of looking at math pull you in
one direction or another more toward it being out
there versus invented or more toward the reverse
i um certainly would also think that
um the the success of mathematics in
application scientific applications points towards
mathematics being out there mathematics being
uh discovered and so sometimes so the examples
you were just referring to it it looked to
me like um what was happening was that we were
eventually revising our physical theories but if
we're talking about purely mathematical theorems
they are eternally true they don't once they're
approved they don't get revised anymore so i i
think it's important to draw that to draw that
distinction um and i think that applicability is
really one of the most forceful arguments in favor
of what philosophers call mathematical realism
the view that mathematics is out there um that
mathematical objects exist independently of human
minds but it's one thing for math to exist as both
you and shelly were referencing as something
that perhaps might be given the label real
versus mathematics being out there as the reality
that we can touch and feel and interact with as
opposed to something that we're able to cogitate
about in some abstract sense so i mean i'm going
to be straightforward about it i waffle on this
question i have changed my mind over the course
of my career between whether math is invented
or discovered i almost can tie it to how well
my research is going when the research is going
really well it kind of feels like all that i'm
doing is like discovering something that that's
out there it just is falling into place and you
feel it has to be out there because it's locking
together with such power and such economy and
and it's so gratifying to see the equations
just really doing what they're doing almost
independently of of the human who might be
scribbling them out on a piece of paper at
other times i've come to the reverse where it just
feels like we're just trying to trying to push
this mathematical description on the external
world and sometimes it resists because it's not
the the right language or the right approach
for actually describing physical arousal so i go
back and forth on this but but you you personally
do do do you come down on that issue with
one uh unassailable and immutable view or
or do you also find it going back and forth
i'm pretty i'm pretty certain that
mathematics is an objective um thing out there
so i've i've never felt very drawn
to fictionalist views of mathematics
um the notion of mathematical fictionalism
that really in some sense what we've done is
we've written this wonderful rubric called
mathematics which is has proven itself capable of
describing the world but we couldn't even describe
the external reality without already having that
rubric to begin with how would we even interpret
the motion of the moon if we didn't have the
mathematical language to talk about it how would
we talk about the motion of particles if we didn't
already have the vocabulary that mathematics
provides us so is that perhaps biasing our view
it might be um though i think it to be fair
i think fictionalists about mathematics are
perfectly happy to say that mathematics is perhaps
an indispensable tool or a very important tool
that we need to uh to do empirical science um and
i think i just think that the the fictionalist
stance the fictionalist philosophical position
arises from an unwillingness to um posit the
existence of abstract objects out there so much
about much of the fiction in this position is a
reaction against mathematical uh realism or uh
platonism even and so i think um fictionalists
arguments have so far not succeeded in convincing
me that there is something wrong with mathematical
realism david earlier mentioned hartree
field he is famous for having managed to
nominalize newtonian gravitational
theory which means that he managed to
reformulate the theory in a way that doesn't refer
at all to mathematical objects or to mathematical
entities it doesn't use any mathematical language
anymore and that's an incredible um achievement
and so that's more than just translating
a mathematical sentence into an english
sentence like force equals g times m1 i mean
all that it's much more than that right than
that it's much more than that yeah there is a
like i said there is a sort of fairly precise
and and fairly compelling once once you follow
the arguments criterion that quine wrote down
to diagnose whether this or that theory that
that you believe in is treating this or that
kind of object as existent okay and and field
in what he was doing was constrained by that
okay and wanted to show that newtonian mechanics
could be formulated um the newtonian mechanics
or the gravitational part of newtonian
mechanics could be formulated in such a way
as to satisfy the condition that according to
quine's criterion of existence it didn't count
numbers as existing objects and and so does did
that push you in a direction of thinking that
math is auxiliary that math is displaceable
to the extent that you believe something like
that and to the extent that you believe that it
could be extended to to all of natural science
i might say that hartreefield himself
um recently is more pessimistic about
uh the possibility of that project succeeding
than he used to be i was just bringing it up here
because these questions do numbers really exist
so on and so forth i it's what's precious in these
conversations is to find some way to get beyond
people scratching their chins and looking as if
they're having profound thoughts and actually find
some criterion that you could get your teeth into
and that you could do some work on and claim
to have discovered the beginnings of answers
to these kinds of questions maybe at the
end of the day this isn't going to pan out
this isn't going to be the right way to decide
which things exist and which don't and there
are going to be these intuitions of the kind that
shelley evoked that this is something mysteriously
that we feel we know with a level of certainty
that we don't experience in any other way and at
the same time it's not something that we can tell
a story as we can with neptune and with reference
to what max was saying i think there's a big
disanalogy between neptune and and claims about
the existence of the number five um or something
like that we know how to tell a story about how we
know about the existence of neptune it's a causal
story okay um it has to do with neptune's having
direct physical influences on a chain of
things that eventually ends up inside our heads
in the case of mathematics we don't have a
story like that a causal story that links
the existence of the number five to a certain
brain state of mind so there's a real dilemma
there there are real powerful intuitive forces
pulling you in two different um directions at the
same time and the thing that's and that's a that's
a tension in which it's imaginable just to remain
forever the thing that's refreshing
about an observation like kwines
is it is it might give you another
direction um another slightly different way
of raising these questions so max the number five
presumably it's never done anything to you you've
never felt the number five you've never reacted
the way you would if a black hole were next to you
what's that well there you go so it has affected
you in some metaphysical way but but does that
description that david just gave make you rethink
it all the analogy with neptune that you gave
i would put no i would push back actually
on this a bit i think the reason that um
the business with causality comes in and
so much in your in your arguments that
you so eloquently made there david is
because you know it's a causality only
makes sense even if once you have the concept of
time right first things are like this and then
that somehow causes things to be like that at
a later time the mathematics in our universe
is at a much deeper level that even transcends
time if you come back and ask questions about
the the things that mathematicians ultimately
really study in mathematical structures there
isn't necessarily even any time there like look
at the cube you know if you study the cube what
properties does it have it has it has six faces
it has 12 edges it has eight corners was the cube
created causally that did the cube once have only
five faces and then no the cube exists completely
outside of time and space as well for that matter
and when we when we look at how our physical
space is thought about in science right einstein
came along and said you know time we should think
of just as the fourth dimension of this
timeless thing called space-time which is
and uh if if the reality they were having
this discussion in right now were a movie then
space-time would be the entire dvd right so uh
what i'm saying here brian and the answer to your
question in response to your question is these
mathematical structures that mathematicians study
they don't exist in time or in space but space
and time exist inside of some of them like inside
of the four-dimensional space-time of einstein
which mathematicians refer to by the nerdy name of
minkowski space and five is just like that
mathematicians don't just study five they study
this one mathematical object called the integers
and five of them five is is is part of that where
the integers ever created there's no reference
to time in there at all and therefore there's no
element of causality in it it's in that sense
that i feel these mathematical structures just
exist and we're not obliged to explain what caused
them to pop into existence because they never did
if i can jump in the the causal story wasn't
about questions about how they got there it came
up in connection with questions about how we know
about them we have a how information about them
if we're thinking of them as things outside of
our heads no less than tables and chairs are
outside of our heads okay there's a question
that arises about how they got from their
positions how information about them got from
outside of our heads to inside of our heads
okay in the case of tables and chairs we have
a story about that how that happens that story
involves causation i completely agree with you
that causation is already a higher level notion
it's based on mathematical ideas so on and
so forth nonetheless once we have this causal
language it gives us a satisfying story about how
we found out about these tables and shares there
may also be a causal story about how the tables
and chairs got there but that's not what we're
concerned with at the moment we're concerned with
how we found out about them i i think the cube
would still have six faces even if it never got
into our head you know if you rewind five billion
years ago and there were no humans if there
were some aliens for some who built this some
super computer that started classifying geometric
objects it it would still get the cube on the list
and the computer with calculator has it's got six
faces and it has eight corners and twelve edges
even if there were no heads at all in existence in
the in the universe at that time and it's in that
sense that i feel that that mathematical structure
it has those properties and data came along and we
found out about them but we didn't make it pop
into existence we just discovered its existence
something that i think and of course sylvia
knows much much more about this than i do
but something that i think has often puzzled
people about mathematical knowledge is that
that kind of an account of how this stuff got
into our heads doesn't seem to be available
in that case we cannot tell a story that is
convincing to us by our by today's standards of
how we have epistemic access to these mathematical
objects that are purportedly out there um i just
wanted to point out that um plato of course had a
story about it he thought that our souls before we
came into existence before we were born our
souls were communing with the eternal forms
and so during life where recollect it's you
know mathematical knowledge is a recollection
of that time but also mathematicians
like godel for example thought that well
we have our five senses with which we perceive
physical objects but we also have mathematical
intuition he believed that you know there
is this mathematical landscape out there
and we perceive it with an additional sense
perhaps we could call it our mathematical sense
and he thought there was nothing you know
particularly perplexing about telling such a story
i think it's just that nowadays we're used to
um you know asking for an empirical story an
empirical explanation for kinds of things
that we can or cannot know and that seems
very difficult in the case of mathematics the
reason we have trouble being satisfied with
how we come to know mathematics is precisely
because we know it so intimately and so well
this would require a lot of elaboration but
um i really do think that's what's going on
it's a bit like consciousness if we know something
directly and intimately maybe we shouldn't expect
to be able to give an account of how we know
it an account of the kind which we feel so
satisfied about about for example knowing that
neptune was there we do the analysis and we're so
satisfied it comes out right but that's because
we knew it indirectly not intimately and that's
true of so much of physics you know we've had
some conversation about math describing the
external world that you know we can touch and feel
and observe and measure and you just brought up
consciousness shelly which is the next section the
next chapter that i wanted to move into which is
the paradigm of equality of the world
that we can't grasp in the way that we can
more familiar physical objects it's something
that as you say we have deep knowledge of
we have intimate connection with and yet it's
something that most people i think intuitively
would think stands outside of mathematics not
something that can be described in that particular
language so is that enough to really understand
consciousness or is consciousness something that
is much more perplexing than any of the qualities
of the world that we've been talking about so far
here's what i tell my students i i basically
with regard to physics i'm basically a pretty
strong reductionist so at the end of the day
our simple like hope will be at the end a simple
t-shirt equation which captures all the physics we
don't have anything like that yet presumably but
the equations we do have are beautiful and they
explain most of what we say around it basically i
say that you know the physics fundamental physics
should explain everything but then i tell my
students once and then leave that out and forget
that for the rest of my of the course i tell them
yes but i lied to you consciousness is left out
physics does not explain everything so you really
think that consciousness is left out uh will not
absolutely i'm i'm absolutely convinced of that
why can you i would let me just say this is not a
challenge if you could convince me of that i would
be eternally grateful because my view is is much
more the first view the reductionist view that the
end of the day were bags of particles governed
by physical law and that's all there is to it
it's a kind of bleak but i think beautiful way
of looking at the world but tell me why i'm wrong
look i couldn't convince
look i had exactly that view
for many many years i think sometime after
i maybe after i finished graduate school
i i suddenly for me it was just an
eye-opening experience saying oh
i was wrong all these years i was so strongly
arguing against all these people who said no no
consciousness can't be accounted for by physics
or mathematics i couldn't understand why people
were saying that and suddenly you know the phase
transition can occurred in my thinking and do
you remember what induced that phase transition
yeah but i don't remember i know it was reading
vigner's remarks on the mind body problem but when
i went back to look at it later to see what was it
precisely in there that did the job for me i
couldn't see what it was so no i'm to me it's
not clear what it was but certainly my thinking
just changed dramatically i mean i think david
chalmers does a great job in three or four hundred
pages of explaining why it is that he thinks
that consciousness transcends
physics and mathematics
but yeah you would like me to convince you of
it i mean i find this is the hardest thing in
the world to convince anybody yeah yeah yeah you
can't remember an hour or two hours three hours
weeks maybe months can do it of discussion
it's maybe it's useful just to list
a couple of reasons that people do give whether
any of these reasons capture what's going on
with shelley there are several different kinds
of reasons that people cite for being deeply
puzzled about how a reduction of consciousness
to physics would work somebody says to me
a bunch of particles arrayed like this and moving
in this way that's a table okay and if i go back
to them and i say why is that a table there's a
lot they can say well look solve the equations of
motion you'll find that particles assembled
in this way will hold up plates and glasses
and you can be convinced that the way we ourselves
recognize what a table is is by means of its
causal interactions with us and with the rest of
the world you can give a very convincing story
about why an assembly of particles
arranged in that way moving in that way
is a table if you try to play the same game with
say the sensation of green or the sensation of
red okay there's a feeling that somebody tells me
the sensation of green is a is a bunch of ions in
your head going this way and the sensation of red
is a bunch of ions in your head going this way
it's just hard to see why why there's something
greener about this kind of motion and redder
about this kind of motion it feels like it feels
like a case of comparing apples and oranges
you just don't know what to say you don't
see what they have to do with one another
you don't see what the connection is and this
is what what shelley talked about in terms of
the intimacy of our acquaintance with these things
is relevant here unlike identifying something as
a table or a chair or an orangutang or a
computer or anything like this plausibly
we pick out all of those things by means of their
causal effects on us the sensation of redness
doesn't seem like that we don't distinguish
red from green in terms of their different
causal effects on us we distinguish them from
one another somehow just by the state of being
in them and conscious phenomenal states
seem like the only things in the world
that have that kind of relationship to us so this
is one reason why people are puzzled um i don't
know if it's shelley's reason it's certainly
certainly there are other ones people cite
suppose i say of myself i'm just a machine i'm
just a collection of billiard balls bouncing
around like this and somebody says why do you
believe that you say i think i have good reasons
for believing that our scientific investigations
of the world suggest that something like that is
true and the guy says gee i'm puzzled you just
claimed that you're the kind of physical system
whose properties including your beliefs are
just determined by the physical laws okay um
but now you're acting as if there's something
else that goes into determining your
beliefs some kind of sensitivity to what's
reasonable but if your model of yourself is
is the correct one that model denies that there
is any kind of additional sensitivity to reasons
if somebody asked me why i believe that two plus
two is four i have the feeling that i can see
how it couldn't not be the case that two
plus two is for this is the kind of certainty
that shelley refers to but if i really take it
seriously that everything about me is just covered
by the initial conditions and the laws of physics
then there's only one explanation available
of why i believe that two plus two is four that's
because of the initial conditions of the world
and uh and the laws of physics okay and there's
nothing about the truth that enters into the
explanation of my belief that two plus two is
four so i would like to inject some optimism here
both to david who was worried that uh his
bouncing particles couldn't really be trusted
in their views about the outside world and to you
shelley who are worried that consciousness can
forever be on physics and reductionism and
also to you brian who was using the word
bleak to describe reductionism so if we start
with you david i think that the reason you
should actually put some trust into what your
bouncing quarks and electrons are having you
tell us about the state of the world is because as
brian said there is this additional story you can
add on top of it the super beans on on just
particle physics it just follows from it
and it's the story of darwinian evolution
we obviously there were probably a lot of
organisms who were really really lousy at taking
information from the environment and coming up
with correct predictions and they got eaten or
starved to death and those who were still around
have evolved to actually tend to have more
reasonable beliefs mostly about what's going on
just to i just want to get the shelley first also
so for the for the this notion that we're forever
doomed to never be able to explain consciousness i
think history actually gives a lot of hope here so
brian mentioned galileo before if if galileo threw
a grape and a hazelnut right he could predict
wonderfully how they would both move in a parabola
and when they would hit the ground but he had no
clue why the grape was green and soft and the
hazelnut was brown and hard and that really
seemed the most scientist at the time to be just
beyond physics how could he ever predict that it
was going to be green but then maxwell's equations
came along and showed that colors and light can be
described by mathematics the schroedinger equation
of quantum mechanics was discovered and helped
us calculate why the hazelnut is hard and and the
grape is soft and gradually physics went from this
situation where it could describe almost nothing
except motion of the phenomena in the world right
to where we are today where it can describe
almost everything and from the subatomic world
you know to our expanding universe and the
formation of black holes and interestingly
what's left the final biggest bastion of
ignorance that we have to try to conquer our
intelligence and consciousness which is exactly
where we we're going in now and um we will come
back and talk about this later but my guess is
that both intelligence and consciousness are
particular kinds of information processing that we
can ultimately also describe with math and in fact
that's the reason why ai has been so successful
recently and making some progress on on the
intelligence side and there are mathematical
theories by giulio tinoni and others also what
they try to do with consciences but i agree we
should be humble we're absolutely not there yet
but we should we should be optimistic that
there's hope and last brian uh you you said
it felt bleak to acknowledge that you're just
a blob of of quarks and electrons evolving
according to the standard model of particle
physics i object to you so i shouldn't say
spoken many people see it as bleak my own view
is it's spectacular that particles and bags and
collections of products do the things that we do
so my view is actually quite the opposite but i
don't know where you come down on it so uh richard
feynman who's inspired me enormously has this very
beautiful uh counter-argument to this you know he
was arguing with an artist who said that euphysis
just ruined everything by trying to describe it
reductionistically you hold up a flower and say
look how beautiful it is but you as a scientist
all take this all apart and it becomes dull thin
first of all i can't appreciate the beauty of a
flower at the same time i see much more about the
flower than he sees i could imagine the cells in
there the complicated actions inside which also
have a beauty i mean it's not just beauty at this
dimension of one centimeter there's also beauty in
the smaller dimensions the inner structure also
the processes the fact that the colors and the
flower evolved in order to attract insects to
pollinate it all kinds of interesting questions
which the science knowledge only adds to the
excitement the mystery and the awe of a flower it
only adds i don't understand how it subtracts the
feynman rose story is a beautiful one that i've
recounted many times too so i i totally agree with
that perspective sylvia i just want to turn to you
on this question of of the self-reflective inner
awareness that we human beings have within our
heads do you see that as part of a mathematical
description of the world or for instance would you
imagine that other languages or other perspectives
need to be brought in to have a full understanding
of that quality of the world i sometimes feel
that the puzzlement about consciousness and what
we can achieve with mathematical descriptions
of consciousness arise partly from different
meanings that the word description has so
um we can think of all kinds of descriptions
descriptions in different languages so if we think
of conscious conscious experience we could think
of trying to find a mathematical description
of that and that would help us understand um
for example what distinguishes uh conscious
beings from unconscious objects in the world
um and so what we the goal of such a description
would be to enlighten us on the physics underlying
conscious experience but we could have a totally
different goal for our description for example to
replicate or to induce a particular phenomenal
experience in another being that we're trying
to describe our conscious experience to and in
order to achieve that goal um a different kind
of description might be much more suitable so
let's say if you had never in your life tasted
vanilla ice cream and i was going to try to
describe to you what it what it tastes like
then perhaps a mathematical description would not
be the best one or let's think about a different
example ice cream is a little bit too too trivial
think about the emotion of fear um i could give
a mathematical explanation of what happens in a
subject's brain when that subject is in a state of
fear i could describe you know which neurons are
firing and what exactly has happened on the on the
particle level in that person's organism but in
order to make you understand assuming that you're
a being who's never had um who's never felt fear
in order to explain to you what fear is like
it might be more useful to use a completely
different kind of description using a different
kind of language let's say the language of
music um it's famously and this also relates
um to what we just heard about you know uh
disputes between physicists and artists famously
art can reveal and communicate let's say knowledge
can communicate things can reveal things to us
that cannot be revealed in a different in
a different way using a different language
so i think we always have to ask what exactly
is it that we want to achieve with a particular
description and if what we want to achieve is
to get a better sense in terms of the underlying
physics of consciousness then my intuition is more
on on max's side i think we can be hopeful that
empirical science will at some point uh be able to
figure out a mathematical model for consciousness
if it's about making another sentient
being understand what my inner life is like
i'm much more skeptical what about morality
just turning the gears a little bit further
human minds human brains are are able to
have a moral sensibility of right and wrong
and good and evil and all those qualities that
are so vital to a rich life here on planet earth
do does morality and those notions
do they stand in your view outside
of the mathematical description or the
mathematical universe or are they subsumed
within it in some deep way that might not be the
most efficient or effective way of describing
them but nevertheless they are accounted for in
a mathematical way of thinking about the world
i think mathematics um gives us an interesting
paradigm or an interesting model um that can
help us to try and understand how morality fits
into our empirical world so we've discussed this
earlier in the program that you know people are
some people are drawn to the idea that there
exist mathematical objects other people object
to that idea and think that's completely crazy
because those objects would be so vastly
different from the objects we're familiar with
physical objects and pretty much the same thing
can be said about moral entities you know like um
moral values for example would
be what i call a moral object
and so there are some people out there let's call
them moral realists who believe that morality is
something much like mathematics it's it's eternal
there are eternal truths out there and what we're
trying to do when we think about morality is
to sort of um dock onto those truths like to
capture those truths and um represent them in
our beliefs but that of course entails that moral
objects exist and it's very confusing uh to some
people to to to imagine what that would look like
i think that thinking about mathematics and
seeing that we have good reason to believe in
mathematical realism and we shouldn't be afraid
of positing those entities can actually help us
overcome our scruples also in the moral arena
so one one uh one of the main arguments that is
usually cited in favor of moral anti-realism in
favor of the view that morality is is something
invented something that we constructed for some
evolutionary purpose one of the main arguments is
always disagreement we vastly or human beings
vastly disagree on what are the moral truths
therefore there cannot be any substantial
truths out there now i think there are a
number of reasons why that argument is is flawed
but um the com the the comparison to mathematics
can lend credibility to the view of
moral realism and here is the comparison
if the reason to reject realism about morality is
fundamental disagreement we have the same also in
the mathematical arena it's true that mathematics
is often viewed as this sort of disagreement-free
cosmos where all that mathematicians are doing
is discover new mathematical theorems or prove
new mathematical theorems but in fact when when
we look at the foundations of mathematics of set
set theory for example we can see that there is
pretty vast disagreement on pretty fundamental
questions also in mathematics for example on the
question how many mathematical universes are there
and so i think that this this main argument
against moral and against moral realism
can be discarded once we turn to mathematics so
that's just one way in which the analogy between
mathematics and morality can be enlightening
well i'm not all that comfortable with the
plurality of mathematical truths in the sense
that genuinely conflicting mathematical truths i
that's something i have trouble understanding um
i do think the analogy between mathematics and
morality is a useful one just as justice sylvia
said and of course the big difference is that i
at least for most people and that's i think well
i don't know about most people for me in any case
um mathematical truths force themselves on
me with a con compulsion which is at least
somewhat lacking when it comes to moral truths
i'm not a moral relative a moral realist but um
nonetheless uh the mathematical realism that
just seemed to that i that i thought i feel
much more strongly maybe a distinction however
is relevant not sure it's a sensible one or not
with a distinction which would apply both to
mathematicals mathematical reality and moral
reality and that the distinction is this what is
mathematical realism what is moral realism in both
cases you might say you might say the mathematical
realism you believe in the objectivity
of mathematical propositions or moral truths
you believe for example somehow that there there
really is it's not there are an infinite number
of primes and there always were and you did there
didn't have to be people around for that to be
true there simply are an infinite number of primes
that's certainly a view that a
mathematical realist would have
now for many mathematical realists if not most
and many would david might say how will you how
would you maybe you're forced to have this view
but i know many people would say but i do not
want to insist that there are mathematical
objects somehow i i don't believe there's a
separate realm of mathematical objects there's
a realm of mathematical truth i can certainly
say that somehow or other there's definitely an
infinite number of primes but i don't believe
prime numbers exist the mathematical objects
themselves don't exist i think that's a view
some people have david any uh any thoughts on the
morality uh math analogy there's an argument that
mathematics is indispensable mathematical some
kind of mathematical realism is indispensable to
the scientific project and i take it there's
no analogous argument in the moral case we
can teach people a whole course of theoretical
physics without mentioning the words good or bad
um but we can't do it without without mentioning
the word five right right can i just that yeah yes
judge our ontological commitments to
mathematical entities with reference to
the scientific project and that's because
the scientific project seems like um
itself like an intrinsically indispensable
project that science is our paradigm for
knowledge at the moment but here is an
alternative indispensability argument for
moral entities or a criterion as david called it
if we cannot not quantify over um moral entities
or normative entities in a project of our lives
that is intrinsic intrinsically indispensable
perhaps not science but something else then
that might also give us a reason to believe
in the existence of uh moral entities and so it
has been argued this is not my argument this is
david enoch's argument it has been argued that
quantifying or referring to normative entities
like reasons or values is indispensable
to the intrinsically indispensable project
of deliberation human beings cannot fail to
deliberate we deliberate all the time in order to
come up with uh well in order to decide
how to behave and how to interact with
the world and in this indispensable project of
deliberation we cannot fail to refer to normative
entities and so that's a sort of analogous
indispensability argument that i think has
definitely some force this question
is actually incredibly timely because
we're now putting rather mathematical based
objects artificial intelligence right in charge
of ever more decisions they're out there now
deciding who gets a loan who does not get a loan
they're having influence of who
gets probation who stays in jail
very controversially some people are even wanting
to build weapons that themselves decide who lives
and who dies right and and then this question of
sort of splits into two parts one is how can you
actually mathematically codify an ethical moral
system so that you can explain it to a machine
a self-driving car or or whatever there's and
this is a booming field now in machine learning
machine ethics and then the separate
question is well okay if you can quantify
mathematically all these different systems
of morality well which one is the best
uh this one clearly there's no consensus on but i
want to inject just a little bit of optimism here
too because frankly i don't think the reason our
world is in such dire straits right now is because
we can't find we haven't managed to answer
exactly that question almost everybody on this
planet agrees that hey it's better if humanity
does not go extinct than if we do go extinct
uh it's better to have less poverty than to have
more poverty so the reason we as a species are
still epically failing at avoiding you know
the risk of nuclear war and avoiding people
starving to death all the time isn't because of
this moral disagreement it's it's more about the
for some reason we just really haven't gotten our
act together and having and in the way we manage
our planet and people often push in a certain
direction because they think it's gonna be in a
way they think is morally good and and it isn't so
i think i think uh the optimistic part is i don't
think we're limited by our understanding of math
and morality and our opportunity to make a better
future so with that optimistic note i want to turn
to uh the final section max one of the ideas that
you are a proponent of in terms of discussion
we've had a little bit around a corner
where we've been discussing sort of the universe
and math either as a description of it or somehow
being part of it or somehow being you know deeply
connected with physical reality you go further and
suggest that perhaps we should turn that question
around and view math as the real reality which
every so often perhaps looks like the physical
reality that we experience but but it's the real
uber you know bottom line most basic reality
that exists i don't know if i'm describing that
accurately but if you could give us you know your
sense of of this view of mathematics and then we
can have some of the folks weigh in as to whether
that's a view that that resonates with them or not
that's right so if you look at the spectrum of
views you can have from it's all in our heads
you know all just invented to somehow it's in
some sense out there i'm as far as you can go i
think on the opposite extreme saying not only does
mathematics describe our universe but our universe
is actually mathematical in the sense that we
live in a gigantic mathematical object and when
you first hear that frankly it sounds ridiculous
it sounds absurd right if you all look around in
the room you're sitting right now if this is
all supposed to be mathematical well i mean
where is the math you know i i'm looking around
in my room outside my window now i see a tree here
you know if something is entirely mathematical
it means that all its properties are mathematical
properties it has only mathematical
properties but that tree there it's green
and brown and it's leafy you know that doesn't
sound like mathematical properties at all so what
am i even talking about well when i look at the
tree again though through my eyes as a physicist
i see a blob of quarks and electrons and what are
the properties of an electron minus one one half
one and of course we physicists have made up nerdy
names for those properties like electric charge
spin and lepton numbers but that was just
the language we made up to refer to those
numbers the properties are just numbers and
and you brian know as well as anybody that
the only difference between an electron and an up
quark is what numbers its properties are and then
what about so if all the stuff in our space has
only mathematical properties then what about the
space itself what properties does space have well
if it has the property three for example that's
the largest number of fingers i can put that are
perpendicular to each other again we made up a
fancy name for that we call it the dimensionality
of the space but that word is just the word we
made up like the word neptune the property of
space is three and then we heard earlier you
the non-euclidean geometry came up we now know
that space also has properties of curvature
and topology which you study in in graduate math
classes they're entirely mathematical properties
so if you accept the idea that all the stuff
in space as well as space itself actually
seems as far as we can tell as physicists have no
properties at all except mathematical properties
then it starts to sound a
little bit less insane that
maybe our entire physical reality
is in fact a mathematical object max
is your view com is your view compatible with
the view that which you don't presumably don't
have but is it compatible with the view that
consciousness transcends mathematics and physics
i would guess that consciousness and intelligence
are certain kinds of information processing
uh not all kinds of information processing but
the one day someone will discover an equation and
maybe julia tinoni already has it such that when
the information processing obeys that there is
a subjective experience there like david albert so
eloquently um described um and information itself
of course as we learned from claude shannon is
shouldn't be described entirely mathematically
as well so by max along the lines of the you know
the the minus one and the half you know in terms
of electric charge and spin and so forth of course
i totally understand where you're coming from and
yes if you were to ask me what is an electron like
what really is it i would ultimately be forced to
give the description that you are rehearsing you
know i'd give you its charge as a number i'd give
you a spin and i wouldn't be able to talk about
electron-ness in any other more fundamental less
mathematical way but but that still could be a
human description of the electron as opposed to
the real intrinsic electron-ness of that particle
right it could still be us humans imposing a
description we developed this tool and it does a
good job a great job but it could still be that no
it's really fascinating i think
historically and i'm so grateful
sylvia for you giving us this
this historical perspective how
again and again uh if you took just traditional
materialism saying oh there's this stuff
as if we knew what that really was right how
all the non-mathematical properties we used to
talk about one by one have just sort of melted
away and we just seem to be left with only the
mathematical ones uh even the fact that there is
a particle there an electron we know now of course
is also an oversimplification there is this thing
called a quantum field and how many electrons
are in there it just tells you something about
that state in the field it's like how much the
guitar string is vibrating how excited is some
mode of this um entirely mathematical right and
then came quantum mechanics and said well actually
you describe the whole thing with a wave function
that lives in this place called the hilbert
space completely mathematical things
and i i think i i find it very intriguing that
throughout the history of physics whenever we
have found that some mathematical description of
the world was inadequate it wasn't quite right
and we had a revolution and replaced it by
something else that something else was also
mathematical and the most ambitious attempt so far
to find a single set of equations you can put on a
t-shirt maybe in the future string theory as you
know better than anyone else on this here on this
this panel brian is entirely mathematical too i
really don't see any evidence so far from nature
that there's anything non-mathematical about
the world now if i understand you go much
further than what you've so far recounted you
would actually go so far as to say that all
of mathematics is as real or i should say any
piece of mathematics is as real as any other piece
of math you don't distinguish between math that's
relevant to reality and method isn't relevant is
that is that an accurate description that's right
they sometimes call that the level four multiverse
so when we talk about something existing if we say
that pink elephants don't exist what we secretly
tend to mean by that is why they don't exist
here on earth or anywhere where we've looked
um but maybe there's another planet really really
far away whether you actually have pink elephants
somewhere else right and um we've gone through
this progression in history where again and
again and again we've come to realize that the
totality of physical reality that exists is just
way bigger than we thought then everything we knew
about is just a small part of something grander
a planet you know solar system a galaxy a galaxy
cluster our observable universe it's probably much
bigger than the part that we can see that
light has reached us from etc and if what
i'm saying what i'm guessing is true then it's
bigger still so you have all of these different
mathematical structures that mathematicians like
shelley can study the cube a columbia manifold
you know minkowski space three plus one
dimensional manifold the hilbert space etc
if they're you know hilbert the mathematician who
was quoted earlier famously said that mathematical
existence is just a freedom from contradiction
there are a lot of different objects that exist
mathematically and my guess is that we inhabit one
of them and if there are other ones which are also
complicated enough that some of their inhabitants
are conscious and have experiences they're gonna
feel that their exists physically and just the
same as we feel that ours exists physically and
in just a sense the same sense that if you brian
were actually right now in a some future very
high tech computer game you know this governed
by mathematical laws you know you wouldn't feel
any different you would feel of course my
my little game world here exists and i can
punch the table it'll punch me back um so yes if
this is true i think this uh copernican revolution
needs to go one step farther and and there
is the ultimate reality is still much bigger
than we thought david any any thoughts on
whether we might be living in sort of the
the mathematical reality of all equations being
instantiated in some way shape or form i mean
first of all they don't i
all i'm going to be able to express about this is
a certain kind of bafflement um about what's going
on and how i'm supposed to understand it i mean
when um max when you say um our description of the
world has gotten more and more mathematical more
and more of the non-mathematical things have been
eliminated i'm not sure i understand what that
means you talk about you know plato and aristotle
sitting around or cavemen sitting around the
the nobody would have doubted that the tree that
they're looking at has some volume okay and you
can assign a number to that okay um what number
you design is gonna is a sign is gonna depend of
course on your choice of units and that's no less
true for the electron spin um um than it is for
the people sitting around looking at a tree but
do we think they would have denied that the tree
has a volume do we think they would have denied
that the tree has a mathematical description
it's just that you seem to want to collapse
um any distinction between the mathematical
description of these things and the things being
mathematically described and there i just really
get confused it's as if you know if somebody comes
up to me and tells me all of these perplexities
that you're having are going to evaporate
if you can just get it into your head that a
cucumber is really a ferrari okay and and if you
can just get your head around that everything's
going to be fine and i sit there saying cucumber
ferrari cucumber all i have to do is figure out
how to see that a cucumber is really a ferrari
i can't do it i don't know what i'm being asked
i don't know what i'm being asked to imagine
and i don't know what i'm being asked
to imagine when somebody tells me
no it's not just that the tree has a volume that
can be expressed by a number it's that the tree
is the number um like i say i'm just being
thick-headed here uh i'm just being stupid
i don't understand what it is that i'm asked to
being asked to imagine so it's a it's a it's a
fair question but i think it's one that has a
good answer there is something that's really
fundamentally changed in our understanding of
trees in the past thousands of years in the
beginning when archimedes was studying trees and
galileo was studying trees there were some very
limited aspects of the of the properties of the
tree that they could describe mathematically they
could describe how long it would take for a branch
to fall down if it fell off and stuff like that
but they had no idea why the wood was so rigid
and stiff and why the bark looked brown and so on
there were measurements you could make of the
tree that you just had no mathematical way of
calculating the answer to that's just really
changed today we really there are still there
are there's no evidence i would say that there
is that you couldn't if you were to sufficiently
if you were to that you couldn't at least in
principle derive all properties of a tree from
the standard model of particle physics we know
in math just because you have the fundamental
equations does not mean you can always calculate
things accurately you know we can't even calculate
the mass of the proton relative to the neutron
accurately even though we really think we know
gladys qcd right um we're in computing exactly
how the tree is gonna grow up just from knowing
its dna you know right now it's beyond our
ability to compute but i would say there's
the evidence that there's something
more to the tree than a quark blob has
sort of melted away that that's not true of all
of physics uh consciousness and intelligence
especially consciousness i think we have to
be very open-minded that maybe we're missing
something big but certainly with with trees i
think uh there's every reason to believe that
we've got the fundamental description
of it right and it's mathematical and
now we're struggling with how we can
link that to the sort of higher level
uh processes that are going on of a growing living
max if i can just push back a little bit look
everybody would have agreed thousands of years
ago that trees have tiny little pieces okay and
that trees are in some sense the sum of their tiny
little pieces okay um um and probably they would
have agreed that the pieces are in some sense
simpler than than the whole tree itself still
i don't understand how that takes us one inch
in the direction of saying something like the
tree just is numbers um we we're getting better
and better at not only describing the tree using
numbers but predicting how the tree is going to
behave in a way that that um that in a limitably
makes use of numbers okay but if somebody
says um here you got two apples here um
so i don't know what the next move is to be is
supposed to be so really all you have here is
the number two if you really think of it i i it it
really feels like cucumbers and ferraris i don't
want to talk smack about cavemen or physicists
from 2000 years ago but they did not understand
that trees are made of air primarily that
they actually take carbon dioxide out of this
out of this the air and sunlight they take energy
to bind it in and and and so on uh these are new
things they were just missing they didn't have a
complete understanding of of the makeup of trees
that we now do right and
whereas now i think we're at the point where there
really is no evidence that trees are made of a new
kind of quark that hasn't yet been discovered
or that you have to overthrow string theory
to describe trees the second point that you
raise which is also very important is i think
the distinction between saying that something
is described by math and saying that it is
mathematical and that might be related to your
cucumber ferrari issue so right in mathematics
there's a very beautiful uh body at work on
on equivalence there are many different ways
in which you can mathematically describe
for example the integers piano wrote down
five axioms and the certain descriptions you
can you can start in many different places
you can use different symbols different notation
and when we talk about a mathematical structure
what we actually mean isn't any one description
of it but we mean the equivalence class of that
thing which is described by all the equivalent
descriptions that's the thing that exists so
there isn't in the in in plato's mathematical
realm to different cubes that there is just one
mathematical structure of the cube right and in
the same way if it turns out our physical world
if you if you think of a mathematical structure
just a bunch of abstract elements with relations
between them if that corresponds one-to-one with
the abstract element with with elements in that
we call physical things like super strings or
quarks or whatever and relations between them
and you just have basically two different
descriptions of the same structure
then they are one and the same thing and it's
that in that sense that i say that our physical i
think our physical world really is a mathematical
structure you know you could even write a computer
program that starts to just classify one by one
different structures that exist in mathematics
my guess is that there is a mathematical
structure which is in fact the one that we live in
and since we live in it we have come
up with also the human words to refer
to the entities we talk about we call
them electrons and quarks or whatever
but they are just the names that we humans
have come up with for referring to abstract
mathematical entities well i've certainly enjoyed
our conversation with all of you mathematical
objects if you allow me to use that language
clearly this is an argument that could keep on
going for some time and it's a sharper version
of the very question we began with in terms of
is math a description is math a human invention
is math actually out there or in max's vision is
math the be-all and end-all of reality wherever
we come down on questions like that i think all
of us here and hopefully everyone who's watching
this can get a sense of how beautiful mathematics
is how powerful it is at describing the world
perhaps it's even more than that i began with
some quotes at the beginning of our conversation
i want to end with a few quotes that capture that
spirit first from bertrand russell mathematics
rightly viewed possesses not only truth but
supreme beauty a beauty cold and austere like that
of a sculpture without appeal to any part of our
weaker nature without the gorgeous trappings
of painting or music yet sublimely pure and
capable of a stern perfection such as only the
greatest art can show mariam murzakani said you
have to spend some energy and effort but if
you do you can see the beauty of mathematics
from g.h hardy the mathematician's patterns
like the painters or the poets must be beautiful
the ideas like the colors or the words must
fit together in a harmonious way beauty is
the first test there is no permanent place in the
world for ugly mathematics and finally paul erdos
why are numbers beautiful it's like asking
why is beethoven's ninth symphony beautiful
if you don't see why someone can't tell you i know
numbers are beautiful if they aren't beautiful
nothing is so with that let me just
thank all of you for this wide-ranging
conversation on math and reality thanks so much
for joining us enjoy the conversation and maybe
we'll have the pleasure of picking up these
controversies sometime in the future thank you
so you